ah
[Música]
ah ah ah ah ah ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah ah ah ah
bom a formar uma comunidade que vive que
é 30 quilômetros do centro da cidade no
qual vocês acabaram de ver aqui o índice
de vulnerabilidade social e pessoal é
muito grande por ver essas crianças
há muitas vezes ficar ociosos em inteiro
o que fazer
eu vi que através do esporte se pode
transformar uma comunidade um local onde
que se vive e dentro de sair o que
aconteceu
eu disse vamos trabalhar com atleticano
com o atletismo é o que a educação a
saúde ea segurança assim através de
suisse modifica muitas coisa e à pessoa
com pet consigo próprio não contra si e
dentro desse item disciplina
então há o trabalho é feito com
profissionais qualificados professor de
educação física assistente social
nós temos uma parceria boa aqui a
criança é no turno inverso da escola eu
tentar sempre estudando pra poder
participar
então a gente sempre procurou trazer boa
ideia para a nossa comunidade e dentro
dos heróis do atletismo é muito pouco é
muito importante então eu também sou de
falar muito pouco não sou de falar muito
mais de ações então acho que no
dia-a-dia nossa gente está conseguindo
transformar nossa realidade que é a
nossa comunidade da receita seria mais
ou menos isso aí
[Aplausos]